hello everyone I thought today we're
gonna spend a quiet Sunday but as the
players already had a rest day on
Saturday that they decided on Sunday
we're gonna have some blood here we have
a game between 11:00 Oregon and Fabiana
Corwin and this is quite a matchup it's
around 7:00 of the 2018 candidates
tournament we have 11 Oregon who is
currently and second to land the last
place and Fabiano corona who is
currently in the lead
so definitely Oregon has the white
pieces and he definitely wants to make
up for some some of the not so wise
decisions during the tournament and we
have Fabiano Caruana with the black
pieces who definitely wants to at least
keep his lead if not to extend it and
thanks to Nikki we also have some nice
fresh photos from the tournament so
let's let's check some of them out here
we have a nice close-up of Fabiano
Caruana these are all photos from round
seven here we have also a nice close-up
some black and white artsy photo of
Leven Oregon here we have a nice photo
of the two of them that's only the
opening of the game and here we have a
very nice photo of Leven Oregon and this
is the look of the man who is currently
in second to last place of the
tournament but it's still pondering how
do I win this and how do I challenge
Magnus for the title maybe it could be
done who knows there's still a lot more
games in the in the candidates will just
have to wait and see so without further
ado let's see this game Ariane is white
and he opens with d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6
and Knight to f3 the antonyms oh we have
d5 we transpose into the Queens gambit
declined Knight to c3 and now D captures
on c4 e for now Bishop to Bishop to b4
Bishop to g5 and we have h6
Bishop captures Queen captures and
Bishop captures on c4 c5 we have castles
C captures on d4 and here instead of
capturing back Aragon decides decides to
sacrifice a pawn he plays
'if I've Queen moves and now Knight to
e4 with some ideas of
if Quran is not careful maybe maybe
position this Knight to d6 but also e4
is a very nice word for the night
definitely worthy of a pawn sacrifice
Caruana
castles and we have Queen to e2 Queen to
e4 does seem like the most reasonable
move it's definitely the best move for
white but this isn't the move of someone
who is currently in second the second to
last place in the tournament and wishes
to win the candidates so he that he has
to make something happen
so after castles we have Queen to e2 by
Oregon and now Russia back to e7 karana
wants to control the dark squares around
the black King not allowing Aragon to
initiate and any sort of an attack rook
8 to d1 we have Queen to c7 and now
Bishop to d3 and getting the bishop out
of the way
Knight to d7 and now rook to c1 still
not interested in grabbing that pawn on
d4 Caruana plays Queen to a5 and here
karana
grab that pawn and now he's also
attacking the e5 pawn which is night and
queen and also threatening to capture
the a to pawn but onion again has to
make something happen
he plays g4 I haven't caught a glimpse
of the live coverage so I don't know
what were the time controls at the time
this move was played I don't know if
this is all in Oregon's home preparation
or is this just some inspiration over
the board to make something happen
either way if any of you got the live
coverage to share in the comments Knight
captures on e5 Khurana gladly grabs the
pawn Knight captures Queen captures and
now f4 Queen goes back to a5 and now
comes g5 Aragon wants to break open the
Kings side Queen back to d8 and now h4
Bishop to d7 we have G captures on h6
and now g6 Aragon pushes h5 and it seems
that Aragon is successful in breaking
open the Kings side if he can somehow
get rid of his game from g1 and places
rocks maybe and G 1 and H 1 that will be
excellent for him so King to h8 by
Caruana and now King to H 2 making room
for the rooks
Bishop to c6 we have rook to f3 and now
comes Bishop to d6 pinning that F
for pawn and now Queen to f2 with the
idea of capturing that d4 pawn would
check
Bishop to c7 now the Queen also protects
the d4 pawn and we have a king all the
way to h3 unpinning Queen to e7 and now
Knight to g5 and Knight to g5 is a very
interesting idea aragon offers his rook
on f3
if karana would capture it Queen
captures on f3 it would it would still
be a fine position for black but her
white would definitely have a lot of
counter play a corona doesn't go for
this he really enjoys his bishop pair
eyeing all the way here to the White
King so no reason to give up the bishop
pair he pushes a 5 and it's a better
decision
he's already up material he doesn't want
to grab more material and risk his
position now he's threatening efore to
win the game simply so Aragon here is
basically forced to give up his broken
c1 but his rock and c1 isn't really
doing nothing the bishop on g6 is a very
dangerous piece Rock captures on c6 b
captures on c6 and now are in our place
and Knight captures on f7 again
this move is basically forced white
can't afford the slow move he can't
afford the corona too pushy for and here
capturing what the Queen would
definitely be a mistake for black
because now after H captures on g6 Queen
moves with check and f5 these triple
pawns I mean not triple pawns but uh but
a 3-connected passed pawns
would definitely compensate for blacks
act extra Brooke but after Knight
captures on f7 would check Caruana
doesn't of course capture with the Queen
he plays rook captures on f7 and now
white doesn't have the option after H
captures on g6 he plays rook to f6 and
now there is no time for f5 if f5 didn't
e4 wins the game
simple as that so after rook to f6
Aragon again has to make something
happen he plays g7 with Czech we have
King to g8 and now Bishop to c4 with
check King goes back to h7 and now again
you see why this Queen is so important
on e7 Bishop to d3 now is impossible
because simply for again wins the game
so Queen to h4 pinning that rock on f6
we have E for now attacking the rook
rook to g3 and Bishop captures on f4 and
here again arrogance replies basically
forced you can't allow a move like ro
captures on h6 this one's the Queen and
the game so g8 this comes with check
rope captures and Bishop captures would
check so Aragon did win a rock here King
to h8 and now comes Rock to g7 and there
were some more ideas here but none of
them really worked for white you could
try something like rook to g6 simply
pinning that rook attacking the pin
piece because the Queen is undefended
but black easily wins this would Queen
to d7 check now we have to make a
decision now you're rockin g6 is
undefended and if you defend rook you
move it rough to g4 then again rook to
h6 wins the game so after this came to
h8 our own I tried rook to g7 attacking
the Queen and here after Fabiano played
Queen to f8 it was in this position that
11 Aragon resigned in the game so and
not really not not definitely not a
great start and we're already at the
half of the tournament and I don't know
I haven't seen the standings yet
I know Cara can finish this game so I
think it's fair to say that our union is
currently in the last place in the
tournament and the cargo car one I
extended his lead by one one point so
definitely a brilliant tournament so far
by Fabiano Caruana I will definitely
show at least another game from round 7
so I will also include the standings
after all the rounds have finished but
yeah I mean Aragon with the white piece
against Fabiano Caruana
losing a game like this it's definitely
due to the fact that he is down two
points in this tournament now he's down
three points in this tournament and I
don't I don't see a way for Aragon
winning the candidates anymore but you
know it it's not out of the question he
could he could still win all the games
and
and when the candidates but it would be
it would be quite a feat so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I will definitely cover one more game
like I said I thought it was it was
gonna be a quiet Sunday we're gonna see
a lot of draws but not likely
and today is vastly when she was
birthday so I wanted to show a game from
round one of the European visual
Championship who were lastly when she
won a very nice game with the black
pieces but I think I will have to wait
with that game until tomorrow but yeah
once again I would like to thank Nick
uriga for her photos from round seven
and every other round like I said you
can find all of the all of the links to
her social media and the description
below so if you enjoy just photography
feel free to follow her and yeah that's
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon with
another interesting game from the
candidates thank you all